- Zanna Roberts Rassi!
- Hello! Hello, hello!
What a great week. What a beautiful week.
- It has been such a good week.
And we've talked about doing this
for so long since the
inception of the show.
Zan and I are always collaborating
and we've been gushing all week long.
And I actually wanted to pick two
of my favorite products from Milk Makeup,
and here they are, okay.
- [Zanna] I'm intrigued to see
what you picked by the way.
- You know, I went a little
OG with the Blur Stick.
Now Blur Sticks are,
there's not another one
out there like this.
It is a,
it is a one color.
- Mm hmm.
Universal.
- Universal color, thank you.
And when this came out,
blur sticks were really on trend
and they were about to pop.
And I had actually happened
to take a trip to South Korea.
I was doing annual trips
there for research.
- Right.
- I go to all the labs.
You cannot find another product like this.
This is like an Instagram
filter on your face.
This does not exist in other companies.
And when a lot of people
talk about blurring,
it's actually a little bit greasy,
and this is the exact opposite.
This is mattifying. It's a primer.
It's magic.
It's an unparalleled product
like nothing else I've ever seen.
There's no performance like it.
- Wow. What a compliment.
I mean, it is, it's silicone free.
Hence the reason it doesn't
leave you any dewyness.
and it doesn't clog your pores.
It actually diminishes pores by like 70%.
- It's literally a filter for your face.
And then my other one
is this Star Tattoo Pen.
And I just, I love it so much.
And it makes me so happy.
And you have a heart one too that I love
and you can do this on your face.
It just makes me so happy.
The Astrology Pen.
I just, I love it.
- A Pisces, we've both got,
I mean, it's the perfect tattoo
for the commitment phobe.
And they stay on until
you want to take them off
with any oil remover.
- I love it, and you picked two
Flower products?
- Of course I did!
Okay, so this week I've been
having my makeup done here
and I've been using all Flower.
This, my friend, I am obsessed with it.
It's the Supernova Celestial Gel.
And it goes under,
I'm just gonna say,
the Skin Elixir, sorry.
- Yeah.
- What is in this?
Because it's like unicorn juice.
It literally, put it under the foundation,
and my skin glows from within.
- See, what I love that you
gravitated towards this product.
And you know is that I was challenged
when I found this formula,
that it would be too
expensive for our line.
And I fought and fought and fought.
And I think the beauty industry,
as well as many others, is a
go with your gut and listen,
it doesn't always work out
and it can flop big time
and you could be super bummed
that you were the one fighting
for something that doesn't work.
But this has been our
number one selling product
since it launched.
And it's, I say, #WakeUpYourMakeup.
Instead of adding more,
just dab with that,
it works with foundation.
- Look at this.
- I'm so glad you like it.
'Cause you are so knowledgeable.
I mean, when you are doing
Milk and you created Milk,
you know, what was one of
your goals with the company?
- Well, I think, you know, I
can't talk about Milk Makeup
without talking about
my amazing co-founders.
Dianna Ruth creates all the products.
Georgie Greville is a creative director.
And my husband, Rassi,
who founded Milk Studios
is also a co-founder.
It's fun to be a partner
with your partner.
But we created multitasking smart products
for busy creative people.
It was always about the person on the go.
We wanted them super utilitarian.
Like you see in this stick here.
Very easy, no fuss, but most of all,
they had to be clean and vegan.
- You also challenged with KUSH.
- Yes!
- And CBD,
everybody got on that
train, but you were first.
- We were really challenged.
We wanted to put hemp derived
cannabis oil in a mascara,
which had never been done before.
We were challenged. Was this a good idea?
And as you said, now, it was,
it's just everywhere now.
And it was such a good move
and we stuck with our gut.
And I think that's such
a great learning lesson
in any business
- Also, we're companies that can be nimble
and go with something
within a matter of months
rather than years, which
is very fortunate for us.
And we can speak to
trends and gut instincts
and learning curves.
(upbeat music)